all right good morning my name is uh
Michael Walters I work over at Capital
One and so apologies upfront this is not
a heavy coding presentation so but
you're getting some coding samples at
the at the end but this is more of a LOD
to kind of reactive thinking and not
just the type of reactive thinking that
maybe you've read on like you know the
react X and some of the other sites out
there or if you've taken certain pledges
this is actually this kind of reactive
thinking you find in a lot of different
areas in what we do
and so you can kind of go into that a
little bit give some examples and then
yes do i all right I will project even
louder okay so in application
development you know there are many best
practices and methodologies that have
come out in the in recent years that are
you know in juxtaposition to what's come
out in the past and what I'm going to
propose is that a lot of those are going
from being more of a proactive mindset
to a kind of a reactive mindset
so this is the the famous black peppered
moth so this is a prime example of what
we call industrial melanism so during
the industrial age in England this moth
evolved from being a peppered moth up
here to a much darker peppered moth and
how it did this is it would sit on trees
and birds would fly around and before
the Industrial Age your peppered moth up
here was was much less likely at eaten
by birds but as industrial pollution
puts it and etc on all the tree trunks
the darker moth became the more dominant
of the black pepper North species and
there's other examples that we see as
well so there's the you know currently
like the Canadian squirrel the ones that
breed a little bit earlier are actually
starting to thrive so they they spring
used to be frozen in Canada and now the
squirrels are that breed a little bit
earlier dominating and there's many
other examples as well and you know one
way to look at this is cool it took
about a hundred years and from basically
you know close to zero percent to the
end of the nineteenth century
close to 100 percent of the moths were
dark but you know we as people and as
humans in our world we can't really work
like that like that's just way too slow
and one other thing is how does
evolution work so the the Mafia had
already already had this trait it had if
you will been proactive in its species
about having some ability to turn dark
so there were a few dark moths out there
before the Industrial Age getting eaten
by moths once in a while or Birds and
what a waste
if we had to do that with all of the
things that we build that be crappy oh
but we do so there are examples from you
know a few years ago java application
servers where there was a lot of
pre-built functionality interoperability
with third-party components this was the
kind of core value prop of the java
applications every would handle all the
tough stuff for you unfortunately what
happened is the java application server
and had all this proactivity if you will
built into the system and what happened
is over years it become came
and more behind what was the current in
technology you know other side effects
not specifically related to its kind of
productivity is it really hard to
upgrade so if you wanted to upgrade one
little piece of it you had to upgrade
the whole thing it got in the way of
trying to react to what you needed to do
with your application you had to go and
upgrade the entire monolith it got in
the way of reacting quickly it also
turned developers into application
server specialists which is its own form
of evil now out in the natural world
there are animals out there that are
that are reactive of nature so the the
chameleon for example it spent its
energy learning to react the world so
instead of the moth which took a hundred
years to become you know turn from the
peppered moth to a darker path the
peppered moth the chameleon would have
been just fine it had built in a
mechanisms to react to the world
so the there's a inspiration for this
talk so if anybody seen Brett Victor's
inventing out principle so he you know
was looking for a way to inspire himself
for the type of you know applications
and coding that he was doing you know it
wasn't just was he just building or is
he building for a purpose for principle
as he said
right
apologies yeah
[Music]
should be coming
[Music]
apologies about that
so what Brett Victor proposes that we
find a principle to believe in and that
you find this necessary to put into your
work you know almost something that if
it's not there it's just it's irritating
to you and he gave some really good
examples so firstly he showed what he
built so Brett Victor's principle was
that craters need an immediate
connection with what they built so he
built a whole framework that when he
updated some his JavaScript the tree
over here would immediately change color
or change shape that there wouldn't be a
reload effect or anything like that
there was it was immediate he found that
the that kind of like loss of time that
you get when you're developing and you
have to compile run to see if it works
and then go back as a as a pure
irritation to his life and so he went
about developing ways to not do that
Larry Tesler famous for inventing copy
and paste actually really hated modes so
I actually love VI but the he hated VI
with a passion and anything that would
cause you to have to essentially create
a new mode in order to make to do
something probably the heat of the shift
key the so he used this know modes kind
of a mindset to go and think of things
like developing copy and paste
functionality Richard Stallman software
must be free so this is a driving
principle in all of his activities and
dunkels Engelbert so invented the mouse
but really what drove his what inspired
him to build was that he wanted better
interaction between the human and the
computer and what's this opposed that to
this is a there's they're they're
craftsmen and and problem solvers people
that go from one thing to another fix it
engineer it move on with their lives
they're not really building for in
they don't have an inspiration or
principle so breakfast or gave the
example of like Thomas Edison he wasn't
really building for any kind of like
main goal he just was an engineer and
loved to build and that's fine but you
know is it better to kind of build for a
principle and so I've been thinking
about this for a while and came up with
my principle and that's a prioritize for
reactive attributes and do not waste
time trying to be proactive the world is
a changing place technologies change all
the time in the applications that we
build requirements change timelines
change if I want to sit around and
proactively come across think of all the
things that may or may not happen and
most of them end up in the knot category
I just won't be able to move ahead so
what if I spend all of my energies
learning how to react to uncertain
situations faster that if in every
single aspect of when I'm you know
designing or building a product that I
take this reactivity mindset and apply
it to it and so some of the goals that
we want are to minimize inertia so that
time when things go to committee that
time when nobody knows what the next
step is to do that's a killer for my
reactive solution faster response times
similar to inertia in concept but the
causes are a little different we just
want to be fast what are the things that
we can build into our systems
applications and the way we manage our
products that are gonna make things
quicker faster and being resilient you
know if I'm gonna rely on being reacting
to situations I need to not fall over
when things when bad things happen
either from within my application or
managing the applications or any aspect
of my life really
that's as opposed to your you know
you're proactive thinker who maybe is
gonna be thinking a lot more about the
things that are going to be the bullets
that are flying the direction so in the
rest this talk I'm going to review some
rules of thumbs that will help you react
faster as we build our apps and let's go
let's go a little Rumsfeld ian first
just to set set the context a little
more i if anybody's not seeing the
rumsfeld on this it's just it's it's
amusing but it's a really great concept
and so this is really just a way of kind
of how do you manage and assess risk
it's a it's a primer that there's are
known knowns is the the things you know
you know there's your unknown knowns
there's you know I know oh sorry
there's your known unknowns there's the
things I know that are out there but I
don't know exactly when they're in the
core so an example that's like a I you
know airlines will can't will flight
will be cancelled
sometimes I can plan for that I don't
know when it's going to occur when it's
not going to occur but it's possibility
and then in Donald run smells world he
said that there's your unknown unknowns
there's things I don't know that I don't
know now but I do know that they existed
they're out there and he went further
I'll just read this little quote he says
and if you look throughout the history
of our country and other free countries
it's this latter category the unknown
unknowns that tend to be the difficult
ones so there are things that you and
why is that you can't be proactive about
them I don't know all of these unknown
unknowns but if I build systems or great
at reacting if I plan reactively and if
I you know put in mechanisms and allow
me to make quick snap and good judgments
then I'll be able to handle this much
better
Rumsfeld didn't really go into the the
unknown knowns but these are you know
these are actually things that you want
to ignore about yourself that are
actually true so you know and in
technology there's there's a lot of
teams that maybe like they they you know
act in a waterfall method or the Acton
water wealth method but they they claim
it's a agile what for Rumsfeld it was
you know this the awful prisons at Abu
Ghraib and etc like we knew they were
bad but we chose to mentally ignore
those those problems for an organization
like the you know the US government or
the military you know they can afford to
be proactive they get like roughly about
three point five percent of the GDP they
have resources upon resources that's not
true for pretty much anybody in this
room they can plan for all the proactive
things out there but if your resource
constrained at all planning to be to
react faster is going to be your better
bet
so let's go into a couple of different
areas where this uh what it supplies so
organizational structures what are the
things our teens to allow us to act
faster so you know one thing to do is to
make sure that everybody knows who's
responsible for what and when a problem
goes down and this applies not this
applies to whoever the responsible party
is it could be an individual a group or
even an application when we need a new
feature to be delivered to a system
which is the which application should
that be built-in or should a new one be
built the those that decision-making
process if we have very you know clear
brand
clear strong boundaries we're gonna
understand who that is there's not a
debate we don't our reaction time is is
short
autonomous responsible parties so we've
all had you know and wanted to add new
features into our applications or needed
to take a timeout to do some you know
build some non-functional requirements
refactoring and etc the deciding body on
who does that if it has to go out to
committee if you have to take it off to
the sales teams and the marketing teams
to to ask if you should do things the
more you can build into your your
organization the that each individual
team out there or responsible party can
make their own decisions the faster
you're going to be a reacting and link
to that is enablement so there has to be
a cultural native enablement so people
can't be afraid to make decisions so
going back to what we that had them the
tardigrade up there earlier but
prioritize resiliency so one of the
important things that if I'm if I'm
going to not spend my time trying to be
proactive I need to make sure that my
other things don't fall down and break
over when
I had and give me time to react
um this only applies to like you know
everybody builds applications with aSG's
and load balancers today I hope but do
apply some things like you know having
you know Newton's - subject matter
experts for any single part of your
application that if any if anybody is
goes on vacation that your your team is
resilient from those skill sets it
applies to you know whatever type of
concept where you have a kind of a
single point of failure linked to that
is dispersed risk so as much as possible
we want to reduce those kind of single
point of failures in our in our systems
so you know in a I'll give example from
Capital One so in Capital One we have
you know a kind of a single you know at
Sidon system so there's like a large you
know LDAP enabled ad environment when
this thing has problems it just creates
sloughs of issues throughout the whole
organization that centralized risk what
that does is it makes it so it makes it
hard for me as a user of that service to
react quickly to changes and then lastly
this is this applies mostly to kind of
people or organizations but you have to
understand your team about whether flat
is better or smaller teams are better so
a flat organization is going to be able
to as new requirements come up as new
objectives come up to be able to swing
over and get the proper amount of
resources working on those problems
faster the problem with that is you
might it's contrary to the strong
boundaries principle so do I know
exactly who to go to in that team to go
and fix a problem when one occurs and
that's versus the small teams do I
create teams of four or five that are
all focused around the same objective
the and I and I think the answer is
Andy Grove had a has this concept called
task relevant maturity and it's really
about teens and individuals how much do
they know about what they're doing are
they subject matter experts domain
experts in what they're building you can
afford to have a flatter organization if
everybody in there is a higher level of
task relevant maturity if everybody kind
of knows what what they're doing that
you don't you you tend not to have that
kind of one or two people problem then
know everything about a problem this
applies to product management so as
we're going and designing what are the
what are the requirements and features
that we want to build into our
application you know a lot of people go
and look at the competition and see to
try and understand what features they
need to build actually the better the
better bet if you want to build for
reactivity is to look at the environment
this allows me to not just look at my
pie and try to get a bigger piece of
piece of my pie but understand better
what are the different pies out there
that I'm not actually building towards
is there are there are other markets
that I could be you know building out or
dominating rather than just continuing
to focus on my own pie key to be able to
do to build a raft as having up data
points so this is where testing comes
into play I can't I can't react if I
don't know what my current state is I
need to be able to understand quickly
what are those inflection points out
there the and so what I need to do is
build it up what I've been coined as
reaction points so iteratively building
out systems where I can understand if
I'm doing building the right thing and
understanding if that's a point when I
need to pivot and change course and the
faster that I do that the faster that
I'll be able to ensure that I'm building
the
thing
I'll cover the the last one here the so
the the product management framework so
which one you know there's waterfall
Kanban I'm scrum you know which one of
these are going to allow me to react
faster to changes so my team's we've all
gone towards the to the the Kanban style
so the Kanban is based around word of
the different work streams what are what
is you know what are teams working on
right now are those are the most
important things to be working on at
that exact moment you know that differs
from your kind of like your scrum agile
which is all about parceling up things
into even pieces of time it's not work
focus as much as making sure that you
understand like what are you know that
your work is all even you can kind of
start tracking velocity and etc but it
doesn't really allow you to prioritize
your work streams as well as as your
Kanban um and I will go into the
waterfall debate but there is a time
place for that application design so you
know in general so a lot of this is I
mentioned that a lot of the kind of you
know the you know modern best practices
and etc the you know we found out in the
system so micro services versus monolith
well I I imagine most people here would
say that in general micro services would
be a better picture but the reason for
that is because micro services ie to
react faster that if one of those
systems needs to be upgraded or changed
you can do it at a much faster velocity
because it's smaller it allows you to
react faster and even pass Internet is a
server list compute so you know if I
don't have to worry about the entire
infrastructure stack and etc if I can
just have lambdas out there that's
fantastic
I even think like for AWS might even
allow you to just slap a docker image
out there and run as a lambda and that'd
be cool so non opinionated frameworks so
you know I'd cover kind of like the the
JBoss and WebLogic so the those were
highly opinionated frameworks
um they you know not only manage how you
ran your web how you interacted with the
database how you built up your ejbs and
etc we also find this out into the
Python world as well so you know using
my kind of what's going to allow me to
react faster mindset I want more control
over the underlying components in my and
my frameworks so when I get into the the
Django versus last debate it's really
easy I have a mindset that tells me I
need to be able to react faster what's
going to what allows me to more control
over all the different components in my
app for your data scientists out there
so when one concept were building into
all of our applications is uh this
concept true sourcing so and that's
getting data that's as as close to the
original source as you as possible it's
it's almost like a rule of nature with a
when you work with data is that the more
kind of like opportunities that somebody
has to do that kind of the tea and the
in the ETL that somebody's going to do
that possibly for a good reason at that
given point but what it means is it
makes it harder for me to understand
what and what's that what is in that
data I'll give an example from a capital
and so we work with the credit cards if
you don't know and the credit card
transaction data has a field in it
that's called the authorized user so
when there's you have an account and if
you have more than one person on account
then there's more than one authorized
user
and within Capital One we had had a
surrogate idea it's called the plastic
sort of a tidy that replace that as we
as we were moving up from the on-prem
out to the out to the cloud a security
person for probably really good reason
said that you know this plastic
surrogate ID
it was breakable as hackable we could
figure out what the actual authorised
account number was and you know that who
knows they'll create some bad things and
what that did though is for our
applications that needed to understand
the different authorized users so
specifically we were building a
recurring transactions model so trying
to understand you know identifying
Netflix as a recurring payment or
Verizon Wireless or even when you write
a check could I identify the Kate that
cadence is a as a recurring payment the
having the authorized user on that was
it was critically important we couldn't
run our models without some key that
identified the different authorized
users and it was just gone if we had a
used true source principle so if we had
not allowed the transformations to
happen in place if we gone through the
necessary steps to get security access
to the to the raw data but even much
better it would allow us to to react
faster event based design I'll get into
that a little bit further partners
resiliency a testing so sure we've one
thing that's important with a if I'm
building in it with a reactive mindset
why testing is is more important is as
I'm going through I want to be able to
understand as I pull out each of my
different components of my applications
as I'm trying to react to the world
faster I want to I need to know if it's
going to impact the rest of my rest of
my system so I said smaller is better
the only way that I'm going to know if
I pull out one piece to react to the
world that it's not going to hit the
Domino and knock over the whole system
is if I have a well-tested platform and
so getting a closed-end so then lastly
this is a little bit on reactive
programming so the the kind of key to
understanding what a reactive program is
it's it's programming with a
asynchronous data structures so um and
another key to that is basically
anything can be treated as a in a
synchronous data structure they're cheap
they're ubiquitous I can treat anything
within the the app as a as some type of
message
there's a data pattern that is used
within a reactive programming called the
observer pattern it's one of the kind of
like you know top 23 from the Gang of
Four and basically the core concept here
is that all variables in your systems
change over time and and those changes
are observable so if we go into a little
bit of a bit of code here so this is a
connecting out to a database doing a
quick select to get the information for
customer IDs 1 3 & 5 so you have a
simple select statement up there and
what this is doing is its building the
here's the observable I can call this
from anywhere in my code the the nice
thing about this is it the the business
logic is very clear there's not a lot of
trying catch blocks in here it's built
into the framework that it's going to
handle errors this right here the this
lambda right here ends up being the
observer there's some call additions I
can put into there to handle errors if I
if I need to in a production application
you probably would but this little bit
of code replaces a lot of no probably
you know probably three or four
functions that you would do to do the
same thing within a standard application
[Music]
and the key here is that this can be you
can basically do this with anything so
this is this kind of a reactive concept
came first from building out websites
but you know here's this example with a
with a disappear database call shows you
can do with anything
[Music]
and then here so if you take this
reactive concept you know instead of
spending all that time and energy
looking to be proactive with yourself as
you go and decide which which framework
to build with your application as you
decide to go and figure out which
feature you should build or how you
should develop you the internals of your
application for me it's what's going to
allow me to react the fastest and what I
encourage you guys to do is also find
that thing that makes you tick what's
the what's that core principle that's
going to make it so your work is a
little bit more meaningful there's gonna
be a driving principle and help you you
know decide the different aspects of
what we do which is uh build
applications so thank you
[Applause]